[Music]
family thinks I joined a sex cult - what
the [ __ ] is this
[Applause]
alright hey Billy blow sake
I'm 24 single live alone and my life has
become crazy recently everyone in my
close family thinks I joined a
psychedelic sex cult when I went to New
Zealand this summer while in New Zealand
I met up with a lady who knew where to
pick psychedelic mushrooms I didn't know
about that when I went to New Zealand we
went to her house you don't trip for the
first time in a different country right
that's why he disappeared your papers
please we went to her house where she
had four dairy cows hot chicks always
hang out with fatter girls don't they
and picked mushroom sorry it was an easy
joke I went with it I'm sorry doll the
plus-size billboard models out there
[Applause]
that's so annoys me now that they put
less pleasant looking people on
billboards now it's like where was that
when I was younger with my blinding
torso okay well we went to her house
where she had four dairy cows and picked
mushrooms out of the cow patties don't
need to see the process cow [ __ ] we
washed them off and then ate them maybe
10 minutes after picking them you didn't
let him sit in the [ __ ] Sun to get
rid of any more bacteria within 20
minutes I'm losing my mind
I pretty much start having massive
anxiety attacked she comes to calm me
down she's so damn hot and sitting on my
lap so I start kissing her 1 this sounds
like a [ __ ] Pink Floyd animated thing
you watch while you're tripping it one
of their things right
one thing turns to another and we [ __ ]
yeah I think one thing turns to another
and then you started kissing her you
don't start kissing her she's sitting on
your lap what then turn to another we
did exactly what everybody thought was
gonna happen
one thing charge do another we put
started bacon bread I felt a connection
with my Higher Being and the collective
consciousness with the woman
how much mushrooms is is this guy
selling right now guys do we gotta go to
New Zealand we got to meet some chick
who has she's gotta have four she's
gotta have four cows craziest experience
of my life
so far so far like we were the same
being dissecting each other's bodies
okay okay I don't know why I just
pictured like dragonflies and insects
there I don't like that all right we
started traveling New Zealand together
the next day and two days after we were
at the beach where we met two guys
please don't do mushrooms with them who
tuckus who took us to a shaman cape man
in a cave this is a trusting person huh
all right he reads our energy and says
the usual hippie [ __ ] like us being old
Souls and [ __ ] he gave us both a hit of
peyote and blessed us what is peyote is
that just like steroid weed no I'll
constant cactus oh okay and we left high
as [ __ ] so we ran around the beach half
naked laughing because of how perfect
everything is la-dee-da we have a good
time and [ __ ] a lot while on
psychedelics you know I'm beginning to
understand why your parents think you
joined a sex color I come back to the
u.s. a couple weeks later and
immediately tell my brother over the
phone my experience I'd been gone for
two and a half months and while I was
gone my brother had a major lifestyle
change and I had no idea he went with
others he was gay he was banging all
these broads and now all of a sudden
it's got a mustache he's got a boyfriend
he went from being an a-list atheist to
on to now a born-again Christian uh-huh
oh come on Hollywood like you don't have
the [ __ ] answers Jesus Christ
oh [ __ ] everything man I moved out of my
hometown I know everything and was very
concerned and upset by my experience
it's safe to say that something happened
to these people is kids like this is
really extreme behavior eating mushrooms
out of cow [ __ ] in New Zealand all right
you guys like well that sounds pretty
normal that's funny that really didn't
get a groan but he's a born-again
Christian oh my god what happened
[Applause]
anyways he doesn't like what I'm doing
so much so that he tells everyone in our
deeply religious family there it is that
I was initiated into a psychedelic sex
cult and now the devil has my spirit oh
I get it I get it he was the black sheep
and now he became the favorite son and
now you're out there banging broads on
mushrooms and they and they're all
waiting for Jesus to come back and
they're jealous okay I get it
my sister blocked me on everything
brother tries to get me to go to rehab
grandma wants me to get baptized in my
mom cries almost every night worried
about my mental health well you're
eating cows [ __ ] I'm gonna guess not
having you know having unprotected sex
in a different hemisphere I would be
concerned she does have a right to be
concerned what do you guys think about
that commercial where they have that the
moms of like soldiers and they go you
know mothers serve - okay I'll give you
that one it's like can they ever hit off
the blue tees I told them that I'm
totally fine and everything has been
blown out of proportion
but they think the devil is making me
say those things oh my god the can you
start filming this please this is like a
reality show I love my family and don't
want to lose contact alright now it got
said but I know they've gone way too far
with this and I'm not really into their
religious outlook and won't go to church
my question is what do I do about my
crazy religious family thinking I'm into
psychedelic sex cults
well maybe stop telling him that's your
[ __ ] broads in New Zealand on [ __ ]
mushrooms I'm not saying to stop doing
that just stop telling your overly
religious family that this is what
you're doing this is one of the easiest
questions ever you can keep your [ __ ]
trap shut thank you for everything you
are and go [ __ ] yourself you're content